yeah thank you very much so first of all
I would like to thank all of you for
still staying after five long talks with
me and then most important I would like
to thank the organizers for the
opportunity to tell you something about
some process generating random
permutations that I've been working on
for some time and I will try to show you
that this is an interesting process
there are interesting results there and
hopefully you will you'll find this
exciting so you know today we have hurt
in the in the morning the tone by
personal chorus was talking us something
about processes of card shuffling when
I'm teaching computer science students
often in the first year one of the first
procedures want to show students is how
to generate random permutations and
there are many ways of doing this but
somehow for example one of the most
natural is natural one is that you have
deck open cars cars or you have n
elements you just choose one at random
you're saying this will be the first
element and you recursively run the same
artwork for the other elements so this
is something which students for example
very happy to implement then they are
finding that you know it's easy to
analyze it's easy to understand and they
think of interaction it works well in
practice which is often not really the
case so first of all if you really want
to implement it you have to generate
random numbers between any range so
first say from 1 to N or from 1 and all
other small numbers then you have to
repeat this n times and if you want to
use it in real practice so if you want
to use this for card shuffling it's kind
of a very slow process if you're trying
try to do it for 25 cards in in a bridge
so we have also seen some other
processes that for example percy been
talking about or some other speakers he
were presenting so I would like to think
about some way of generating random
permutations which is very fun
hopefully is faster than doing this in
an rounds it's simple it suffers well
but it's also in to some extent local or
or distributed so for example that you
know we can just build easily some
machines which will easily be able to do
it quite quickly so there is a framework
that I want to present to you which is
which I called generating random
permutations using switching networks
and again here I will have the following
kind of premises I want to have a way of
generating random permutation in an
oblivious way and later I will explain
what I mean by that and I want to do it
in using networks as underlying
machinery so now I don't really know
whether many of you have seen sorting
networks but what I want to do is
something very similar to what people
are doing in sorting networks so a
sorting network is a network which is
using something to just call the
switches so a switch is something that
you have two inputs to outputs and the
output on the top is a smaller of the
two input numbers and the output of the
bottom is the larger one and in late 70s
and 80s they have been quite a lot of
study of how can we generate how can we
sort numbers using sorting networks so
the idea is that you want to have a sort
network and you are saying whatever is
the input configuration at the end if
you want routing network through it at
the end he will get sorted sequence
there have been some deep studying
computer science about that and there
are some beautiful results would like to
do something similar to generate random
permutations so what do we mean by that
so we would like to use the switch as in
the sorting Network to just decide about
random outcome of of twin be arriving
elements so you know I have a switch
which I'll try to draw in that way so
there are two elements arriving and then
I toss the coin and if there is a head I
would not change the order or there if
there is a tire change that
and now the question is can i generate
can I set up some good networks which
using the random switches which will be
able to generate random permutations
alright so here is an example of of a
network of switching networks so you
know I have elements so usually I'll
just I mean in this talk I will always
draw it as a layered network so here I
have layer 1 so I have 8 elements and
here he random switches depending on the
random outcome the elements will move
forward to the right-hand side so this
is the way how people often won't often
draw it so you know the process is you
have elements and then you just at
random transfer a transfer them from
left to right so what are kind of
important parameters of a network so
number of inputs what is the total
number of switches and what is the depth
number of layers so in this case you
have network with 6 inputs 12 switches
and depth is 5 and of course our main
goal is we would like to generate
something which is like a round
implementation and this would now main
goal how can we do it efficiently so
what is the distribution of Delta
permutation and would like to generate
networks that will generate random
permutations now
maybe you can think that this is some
kind of an odd construct but actually
people have been studying this mostly
because of applications in cryptography
so in pre-pro graphy they have some
money now or he upset he was kind of the
first who observed that if you had such
a network and you can kind of hide the
information so hiding the information
about the way how the element is
transferring transfer from left to right
and then somehow in order really to
detect what is the output input what is
the output you have to reveal very many
of the switches which is because of some
reasons kind of difficult to do in
crypto systems
so really the motivation is our face
coming from one motivations coming from
the cryptography another there has been
some users in distributed computing and
also the point which which on to make
here there are also many natural carts
which a card shuffling schemes which can
be represented in this framework I'm not
sure many but at least one so there is
this table shuffle
so today President Congress was talking
about riffle shuffle which is a very
efficient way of shuffling a deck of
cards and if you think about you know
regular bridge players poker players
this is the way how they are kind of
trying to do it so you take a deck of
ICH deck of cards you approximately half
in half and then you use us as of as
formalities describe use I don't know
binomial or some distribution how you
shuffle the cards if you really want to
do it in algorithmic way or maybe if you
want to build a system a the five date
in riffle shuffle so if you are doing
this you kind of have complicated
probability distribution how you shuffle
the cards it's making things complicated
so tough he is doing it in a much
simpler way
so all this top store shuffle doing so
we have n cards you cut the deck into
two halves and then you do the following
thing you take the first top cards from
each half and you decide that random
which one will be will will be taken
then you take the next top cards and you
repeat this and in this way you kind of
shuffle I mean you shuffle the the whole
deck and you repeat this and the natural
question is how many times you have to
apply the shuttle to obtain something
which resemble random permutation now
there is a very consolation between top
suffering butterfly networks I don't
even know if you know butterfly networks
so networks butterfly networks looks
like that so you have 2 2 K inputs so
kind of on every layer you will have two
okay nodes and there are labels with
binary representation of numbers from 0
to 2 K minus 1 and then somehow only one
you will just have a switch between two
elements de whose last bit different I
won only a 2 you have a switch between
two elements whose second last bit
differ by one and so on so forth and
then this process is equivalent to
Topshop
one can show it in the sense that if you
apply a log in time table shuffles
you'll get exactly switching networks
which correspond to butterfly networks
where n is the number of inputs okay so
what and so there has been some study of
Topshop I don't know if many of your
family away for not they gave me some
conjecture that log and square layers in
butterfly Network we suffice or log and
square table samples for a long time it
was unclear whether we can get poor
logarithmic then bad Maurice he came
first to lock I think 230 something then
there was a paper by Prasad and someone
else who improve it to maybe 17 right
now we have quite good bounce so this is
something like lock cube or lock to the
fourth lock ups only if n number of
input is a power of two okay so what I
would like to study here so I would like
to design good switching networks will
generate random rotations good I mean I
want to have the number of layers as
well as possible and just this time I
use it for humans I want to make sure
that the output so the total variation
of Dalton permutation will differ by
actually in my case this will be pulling
a very small from the uniform
distribution
okay so recommend Simon they have been
interested in networks of this side or
assault because of Crypt applications
and they show many years ago that if you
want to permute on zero ant ones so your
input consists of zero and ones then
after pellagra quick number of layers a
almost every switching network will
generate a random permutation of 0 at
once then with few people we kind of
show that if we want to spam you
different ones we can actually reduce
the stool gorignak number however our
main goal was really not only 0 at once
but but arbitrate rotations so this was
so I remember so if any of you is
familiar with sorting networks that is a
beautiful results about sorting networks
which says if you can sort 0 at once you
can sort everything so you know our
premises was maybe we can actually have
similar theorem in the case of random
permutations we don't know if anything
like that is true so for some time I
thought actually that there is a chance
that the result of this sort is possible
I don't you know if it's true so somehow
you have a network which sort randomly 0
and once and I want to say ok this will
also randomly permute or maybe you will
have to repeat it a few times so I want
to so for some time I found I saw that
show that the result is true now I'm not
sure if anything of that could be
possible
so maybe apply it a few times the same
network so maybe I have network of depth
D and I'm saying it randomly permute
different ones and I'm saying I repeat
it ten times or some number of times or
even log n times even even log n time
yes I don't know if this is true yes I
have been that's what I thought a long
time ago too and I know some other
people so - so okay
excellent ok so I want to show you the
following results so I don't like to
prove the result that there are so
almost every network of logarithmic rank
depth will randomly permute at numbers
and all what I can show right now is
that it will randomly permute almost all
numbers so okay so there are kind of two
reason to main results here so first one
is almost every not network of
logarithmic depth will Vanda will
randomly permute 99% of the elements the
second result is that our show can
construct such networks so one thing is
that this is true for almost every
network and the second one is that we
can construct such networks and then
actually ok so if you like the K wise
independent permutation
the result is that you are generating 1
minus epsilon and wise independent
permutations and then using this it's
not actually difficult to show that we
there are switching networks that in
total will have n log n switches and
will randomly permute on the ramp all
the elements so once you have the claim
for 99% you can extend it to all
elements but the depth is increased
okay so I don't know how to not
increased attempts yes so error is
always polynomial and also so we had
some similar results for table shuffling
which are not really talking here about
but we can show that if we have depths
for the logan square we can again
randomly permute 99% of the elements
any questions okay so so I want to know
some kind of the main results so we can
for almost every Network the switching
Network of logarithmic depth we will
randomly permute 99% of the elements
so almost all switching networks means
we're kind of excluding a fraction of
one over N squared networks now one
should understand I mean there is a very
important distinction between some other
result that I will mention in a second
is that we're kind of fixing the network
in advance so kind of the game is as
follows
someone is giving me the set of all
possible switching networks of
logarithmic depth with made perfect
matching in between every two layer and
I'm kind of taking one of them but then
it's fixed which means I cannot use the
randomness coming from the fact that
this switch somehow it's like a random
because I'm choosing random network so
somehow the input is a network and for
this network I'm showing that it would
randomly commute 99% of the elements if
the result was different when switches
in every face were chosen at random then
it's kind of easy to show that we can
randomly permute after Logan steps so
somehow if in every step you are just
saying okay give me a perfect matching
or actually a matching of linear size
between switches and you repeat this
then it's not very difficult to show
that log and steps will suffice
so here were kind of fixing a network
then you have to actually do the switch
okay so here I want to have that with
poverty 50% and then I need log n
because I will I won't be able to do
anything fasten log n steps okay and
kind of how we are attacking this issue
of almost all switching networks we're
kind of showing that almost all
switching network is something like an
expander and then we are really
analyzing this in the language of
expanders now what does it mean expander
here so it's a well-known fact that if
you I mean we can interpret a well-known
fact in our language so that if you are
looking at any say five consecutive
matchings or layers if your graph
induced by these layers then this this
bar for almost all switching networks
will be an expander so in yes now what
does it what do I mean exactly is the
following thing so let MRI be the
matching between layer I and I plus one
and we define gks to be an undirected
graph with n vertices so that I'm
looking at matchings at matchings MK and
k plus 1 the s following matchings and
i'm just saying where can i come from a
given vertex to any other vertex to any
other vertex using this matchings using
the path and i define the graph in that
way and then the claim is that the
obtained graph will be expanded and here
is an example so for example if I'm
taking graph this G 2 3 which means I'm
taking layer 2 I'm looking at this
vertex and I'm looking what are all
vertices which after
steps can be reached from that vertex
then I would just connected this vertex
to this vertices to the six vertices
such you see you might have power edges
you will have actual parallel as usual
okay so it's not difficult to see that
for almost every network this graph will
be an expander that we want to use this
later okay so now I want to explain to
you how kind of what is the matter how
we are proving the result it's all be
using coupling actual normal carbon
coupling I'm assuming most of you if not
all of you are very well familiar but
still I will say kind of what one to
achieve here so what I need two copies
of the process a PI T and PI T star and
we're assuming you are starting with two
different inputs PI 0 and PI 0 star and
we have transformation so that both of
them PI T to PI T plus 1 and PI T Star
Plus party start pi T plus 1 star are
following the Markov chain and our goal
is to kind of couple these two processes
so that PI T will be equal to PI T star
for us T as multi as possible that's
what coupling is doing and then we have
the theorem that if they are the same
after these steps so if we've good
properties are the same after these
steps then the chain will mix after
these steps ok so now we'll have one
very nice simplification by called puff
coupling so we can assume that actually
these two elements differ by just one
transposition so kind of they differ on
two positions so this is the first thing
and that will slightly loose in our
bound and the second thing is he will be
actually using this non Markovian thing
which means
traditionally when you are defining
coupling you're kind of saying okay
first I'm looking at this transition
then I'm looking at this transition and
so once I have this transition I'm
designing about coupling on the base of
this transition at once but you will be
doing this at the very end so somehow
we'll be first looking at the whole
sequence in one chain and only then
we'll decide how the coupling will be
set up okay okay so
suppose we have some Network supposed to
have permutations that differ by on two
elements and we want to permit only 99%
of elements so we have some number of
zeros or Joker's which we'll be using as
kind of a buffer to establish the
compliment
okay so here's kind of these two copies
okay they differ on these two elements
so now if we are thinking about coupling
the best-case scenario is that you have
PI T and PI T star and they differ at
positions IJ and we have a switch
between positions I enjoy and then it
started thinking coupling that we can
make sure that actually this PI T plus 1
and PI T star plus 1 will become the
same you just use different outcomes of
the coins so our goal is to try to
emulate it what is actually the problem
with this thing of course the chance
that we have to promote a shion's the
different two positions I and J and that
there is a switch between I and J is
very tiny so what we are trying to do we
try to increase the probability that
this match will happen in the algorri so
this will be our goal right now and how
will we do it
so this process that it will speed the
process into two halves
the first noggin layers and then next
layers and we first found a the process
on the first permutation yeah yes so
somebody saw something
want to permute 99% of the elements the
rest are zeros okay so we yes okay so we
will try to construct a configuration
that would increase the probability of a
match between the switches so what we'll
do
we will kind of have to two stages in
first stage so we start with positions
alpha and beta were the two permutations
differ and to a kind of saying okay
we'll have a large number of positions
where alpha can happen and then we'll
have a large number of position where
beta can happen it will make sure that
the probabilities are right this will be
everything suitable for coupling and
then in stage two
we'll just say okay once we have this
large number of positions that there
will be a matching between these
positions and once we have that
everything is done okay so let's go into
details okay so this is stage one so
what we are doing in stage one want to
kind of have this want to increase the
number of positions where this elements
differ so we'll be doing this building
some full binary trees so we'll have one
binary tree starting at version alpha
another at position beta now all these
trees will have will be fully binary
trees will have the same depth so all of
them will have to 2k leaves which will
be linear number and kind of the idea is
that if we set up all the switches in
network outside this tree that I will
show in a second then somehow the
probability that this element alpha will
reach any of the leaves is uniform and
the same is for the element beta okay so
here is kind of an attempt to draw it
nicely which is always a problem so I
will just show this only for one tree so
we have this element alpha which is here
and now we are waiting for the so we are
running a random process and two are
waiting for the very first time this
element will hit a zero will be switched
with a zero because you have linear
number of zeros we know that this will
happen quite quickly so it suddenly this
will happen and right now we are not
fixing the outcome of the switch but
we're fixing outcomes of all the other
switches were running the process but
this kind of is frozen and then we are
again waiting for the branches when
we'll heat another zero
and who are running this and who are
trying to construct such a tree of depth
k where k is log n logarithmic in n and
what will be the feature of this tree
okay so the tree kind of will look like
this and the key property is that
assuming I fix all the switches are
except the switches between these two
elements so this is fixed and right now
I'm saying if I say the switches
uniformly at random here what is that
where this element will happen this
element will have uniform distribution
to reach any of these positions okay why
this is so because I mean because this
is the way how are constructing the tree
okay so now for coupling this would mean
that a once we fix everything outside
that we have uniform position that alpha
will reach any of these elements the
same will happen for beta okay so and
then one can show that the one can prove
that actually a we can always create
such sorry with high probability we can
create trees with this properties if we
have almost every switching Network all
in fact in an expander and now once we
have this trees we want to use these
trees so the leaves of the trees in the
second phase because these are possible
positions where element alpha could be
the distribute and element beta could be
distributed and we are making
observation that in this network right
now so this is the yellow elements are
from possible position for alpha by
alpha beta and right now we are saying
in the next algorithmic number of phases
will have a matching or matching in the
following sense will have a place where
one grey element and yellow will meet
and will have kind of perfect matching
between this element so we'll have a
total K such positions well will have a
match between the elements
the in the definition of the nodes of
your tree were places where you meet a
joker right but I mean you might not
know where the Joker's are after a while
because you've had these switches no no
it's so once look at the red switches I
have so this is the second phase this is
the next II half steps so first I
creating this trees T half steps where T
is the whole time that I'm looking at
and in the remaining T half steps I'm
trying to find metrics strictly speaking
some Joker's may you may not know where
they are
I have only one element in a single tree
I have found a one element which is not
a joker so I know that all other
elements are zeros but my tree is kind
of so all the leaves so this was the
picture of the leaves all the sleeves
were coming from Joker's apart from one
so this is a this is not a junker and
then I'm meeting a joker and then I know
kind of that these two elements one of
these two elements will take this two
positions then I know that I'm waiting
for another joker a different joke yeah
a different Joker so somehow here I have
to pay minus one Joker's where this is a
linear number okay
so later running the second stage and
kind of the result is that I would have
a matching and then I will be able to do
exactly the thing that I wanted to do in
the first phase where is the magic okay
which means I know that I kind of can
enforce the elements to be able to be in
a switch these two elements where is the
difference okay and again I can show
that in almost every networks we can
have such a perfect matching so in short
what we are doing here what kind of we
have two phases in the first phase we
are able to force the difference to have
kind of different number of copies and
in a uniform way and in the second phase
what did I do and in the second phase we
can coordinate the outcomes of the
switches so that we'll be able to match
them in the way I wanted to have in the
first phase okay and then one is doing
this and we are able to show that by
looking at the streets and matchings
were saying that once we have this the
first sequence by 0.1 up to PI T that we
can set the coupling for the stars so
that PI T will be equal to PI T star
with high probability okay once we have
this we have our result in the remaining
few minutes I want to show something
simpler so once we have this actually
it's not very difficult to show that we
can create switching Network with
elegant number of switches but with
depth which is Logan Square this is kind
of so first it was observed by Morris
all the way but this is kind of
something which which is not not very
complicated so we have this network and
we know that it randomly permute say 50%
of the elements so what we know about
this element here okay they are randomly
permute and they are random so now we
are using the second network for the
next and half elements and we are using
the same result and then we are using
then for n quarter and eighth and so on
so forth and if you count number of
switches you will see it so first of all
you will see that the depth is log n
square but the total number of switches
will be still arrogant so this is
something which which again can be done
okay
and
so all together you'll get the result I
just don't okay in the last slide so
when I start thinking about it I mean
actually so my original goal was I
wanted to understand top shuttle we have
been trying to do something all what we
were able to do is to do it for 99% of
rotations I still think that I don't we
know how to generate a switching Network
of a lot of logarithmic depth I think
it's an interesting question and I kind
of I still don't we know what is the
mixing time of Top Chef
I have a very specific question I
wondering about this question for quite
a few years and maybe you know the
answer so suppose that you are allowed
to choose the probabilities of the
switches each switch has probability P
of switching the two elements and and in
addition to choosing the network suppose
an exactly
mutation exactly uniform can you do it
with fewer than n choose two switches I
know many ways exactly I'm choose two
switches very nice question I don't
really know I think it might be
challenging so first of all I want so
for some odd audiences I often actually
make another point that it is easy to
see that this network will never
generate a perfect random permutation
unless it's of I don't know maybe no it
never may be because yeah so exactly so
so because you have this probability 1/2
on every switch so you always have to
approximate the distribution so this is
a very good question whether you can
play anything with with the switches
with probabilities yeah I know but I'm
just saying it's whether you can do
something there are many ways to do it
and choose two switches and I don't know
whether remember then choose 2 minus 1
for any
okay